[Music]
have you ever found yourself at a loss
for words not to worry merriam-webster
is here to help the company was founded
in 1831 but has found ways to stay
relevant it's full dictionaries
available free online it receives about
100 million views every month and the
company constantly tracks what's
trending the merriam-webster Twitter
account has also gained a strong
following his become known for calling
up prominent people when they use words
incorrectly last week the dictionary
slammed United Airlines over its violent
removal of a passenger it tweeted the
definition of volunteer as someone who
does something without being forced
peter Sokolowski is merriam-webster's
editor-at-large welcome thank you so
much so online how much how much online
traffic do you get and is that where
people on that going to that dictionary
oh absolutely I mean the dictionary is
still in print it's also an app a very
popular app and it's online so there's
three different ways to look up a word
and I use probably all three every day a
lot of people do and by the way print is
alive and well it's still profitable
it's just a smaller part of our business
a hundred million pageviews per month
but you've also used Twitter in a way to
engage people in the discussion about
what words really mean absolutely and
we're having a national conversation
about language right now in the
dictionary plays a part in that
conversation people turn to us very
naturally when a public figure uses
language in a remarkable way so for
example with volunteer that was a
statement from United that we were that
we could could report upon we're
reporting the data from that hundred
million pages a month we could see that
the word volunteer had spiked to the top
and so that we know what the people are
curious about by virtue of what they're
looking up online and that's the big
story here I think the background is
that the dictionary online in 1996 was
the first time we could see what people
were actually curious about so the
provocation of curiosity is really what
we reported Peter that's why your
website is being called sassy because
you use the word volunteer on the day
that that United story was just
dominating the headlines book and you're
saying but we're not driving that it's
the public that's right we're reporting
that the truth about words yeah that's
sort of what we've always did done with
the definitions now we can do it with
the data for instance the
the day you have a word of the day on
March 24th that's the day Republican
leaders gathered to discuss repealing
Obamacare your word of the day was
nightmare oh yeah and I have to say
there's no editorializing at all because
that not editorial because those words
were chosen probably 60 days before and
I know because I voiced the podcast for
word of the day and I do it usually a
week or two in advance so the fact is
that was a co-inky-dink that's a
coincidence it's a total coincidence and
here's the thing I mean why is it now
that just copying and pasting the
definition of a word like feminism like
fact like complicit uh-huh why is that
viewed as a subversive act that's the
bigger question well when Kellyanne
Conway said that she didn't identify as
a feminist because it's associated with
in her words as being anti male and
prohibition merriam-webster pointed to
the definition of feminism and said this
the belief that men and women should
have equal rights and opportunities so
what's the goal well that's the
definition so the fact is that was a
great example of an instance where
public figure raised the question of
meaning you know the president said but
said military didn't mean military he
said wiretapping he didn't mean
wiretapping but you didn't want that out
no but we did well that's right but yeah
we did see in the data the people were
checking I think people were checking
they looked up feminism and in that case
as it with for example complicit the
again the the the question of meaning
was raised and and so where do you go
you know the dictionary has a kind of
unique authority and to call balls and
strikes on spelling and meaning because
Gail had asked Ivanka Trump about
complicit that's right at Saturday Night
Live's
yes so it spiked twice once after the
sketch and once after your interview the
the you also introduced new words online
this year you did throw shade I love
that first world problem how do you
describe what you're going to put in
describe your new words the new words
that are added we just added a thousand
new words about a month ago and that's
an old story that's still the same slow
process of lexicography the job of a
dictionary maker is revision you know we
have to make sure that the changing
language is reflected in the pages give
us an example of go ahead of the
dictionary so there are three criteria
we have you know widespread use of a
word so that a lot of people use it in
different publications long term use and
that is that there's evidence of the
word being used in Atkins
sustained way and finally meaningful use
that most of the people who use the word
kind of mean the same thing when they
use it and that's when we can write
what's example of a new word that's been
added well we just added a whole bunch
but I mean net neutrality for example
those are two words in it when we have
when we have compounds like that that
are not self-explanatory we have to add
them as as a single entry binge-watch
another example photobomb you know it's
kind of thing great to have you Peter
it's great to be here if I'm mr. sassy
you like being called 7 as long as we're
sassy and also substantial sassy to
Twitter for definitions that's the in
substantially I like it yet